قالت مراسله الجزيره ان حاله من الترقب
تسود في النيجر مع انتهاء مهله مجموعه
اكواس لقاده الانقلاب من اجل التراجع عنه
ياتي هذا بالتزامن مع تباين مواقف دول
جوار النيجر اذا مقترح التدخل العسكري بعد
تاكيد تشاد عدم مشاركتها فيه وتحفظ
الجزائر بشان الخطوه ودعوه مجلس الشيوخ
النيجيري للدبلوماسيه في التعامل مع الوضع
في النيجر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات مسيناريوهات المحتمله
للاوضاع في النيجر بعد انتهاء مهله ايكواس
وتلويح قاده دولها بالتدخل العسكري وتاكيد
قاده الانقلاب عدم انصياعهم لتهديد اكواس
وما النتائج التي يمكن ان تترتب على لجوء
قاده اكواس الى خيار التدخل العسكري في
النيجر وكيف سيتعامل قاده الانقلاب والدول
الرافضه لهذا التدخل مع هذا الاحتمال وما
التاثيرات المحتمله للتطورات في النيجر
على دول غرب افريقيا والساحل في حال
استمرار الانقلاب او نجاح محاولات وضع
نهايه له سواء بالتفاوض او بالتدخل
العسكري
[موسيقى]
على وقع مخاوف من ان تتحول النيجر الى
ساحه حرب اقليميه بعد تلويح مجموعه
بالتدخل عسكريا فيها لانهاء الانقلاب
وتهديد القاده العسكريين في مالي وبوركينا
فاسو المجاورتين باعتبار تلك الخطوه اعلان
حرب عليهما يحبس النيجريون انفاسهم في
الساعات الاخيره لمهله الايام السبعه التي
منحتها اكواس لقاده الانقلاب يوم الاثنين
الماضي من اجل التراجع عنه مصدر عسكري في
نيام قال للجزيره ان الجيش لن يتراجع عن
اطاحته بالرئيس وتعليقه الدستور على الرغم
من تاكيد مجموعه اكواس النقاده اركان جيوش
دولها فرغوا من وضع خطه بتدخل عسكري محتمل
في النيجر ستكون جاهزه لتفعيل متى لزم
الامر وفق قولهم
في مواقف دول اجوار النيجر الاخرى وبعد
اعلان تشاد عدم مشاركتها في اي تدخل عسكري
محتمل فيه ورفض الجزائر ذلك التدخل
ودعوتها لاعتماد الدبلوماسيه وسيله
لاستعاده الشرعيه في نيامي انحاز مجلس
الشيوخ في نيجيريا الجاره الثالثه للنيجر
الى خيار الدبلوماسيه وصوت لصالح حل
دبلوماسي في النيجر وتفادي اللجوء الى
استخدام القوه في مواجهه تطورات ما بعد
الانقلاب وقال المجلس ان الخيارات
الدبلوماسيه من شانها ان تخدم جميع
الاطراف بشكل افضل في ضوء العلاقه الممتده
بين ابوجا ونيامه كما دعا رئيس مجلس
الشيوخ قاده اكواس الى تعزيز خياراتهم
السياسيه والدبلوماسيه وغيرها من الوسائل
بهدف حل ما سماه المازق السياسي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من نواكشوط
الهيبه ولد الشيخ سيداتي الخبير مشان
الافريقي ومن واشنطن السفير ديفيدشن مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
افريقيا نبدا من نواق شوط سيد الهبه ولد
الشيخ سيداتي هل نحن بصدد حرب اقليميه
بعدما قالته مالي وبركينا فاسو من ان اي
تدخل عسكري سوف يعتبرونه اعتداء عليهما
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الوضع في النيجر يتجه فعلا نحو المجهول
نحو
ظروف غير محدده حتى الان بفعل الاصرار
والتهديدات التي اعلنتها الاكواس وبفعل
اصرار المنطقه في الموضوع في مالي في
بوركينا وحتى في الرفض الشعبي في نيجيريا
التي تحدثتم عنه في مجلس الشيوخ والجزائر
والشد اظن ان التدخل العسكري حتى هذه
اللحظه ما زال خيارا للتلويح واظن ان
المهله حتى قد تنتهي دون ان يكون هناك
تدخل مباشر على الاقل بعدها مباشره لان
حتى الان لم تتهيا الظروف الكافيه للتدخل
العسكري نظرا لمخاطره تجمع على المنطقه
المنطقه ككل على النيجر على نيجيريا
نيجر قد تتحول وقد تعلن في خطوه لاحقه من
هذا اليوم او غدا
تكتيكيا على الاقل سعيها
كونفدراليه مع مالي وبوركينا فاسو
وبالتالي ستزيد الوضع القانوني والوضع
الاقليمي تعقيدا في المنطقه اظن ان
التلويح بلقمداه وان المعطيات العسكريه
والمعطيات
سياسيه للنيجر تجعل المغامره في تدخل
عسكري في هذه الظرفيه له عواقب ومخاطر
كبيره جدا يوازي هذا الخيار في حاله عدم
تدخل العسكري في حال عدم التدخل العسكري
ايضا بقاء الانقلابيين واتساع رقعه
انقلابات وموجه جديده من اللا استقرار ومن
العسكره قد تجوب معظم بلدان افريقيا
ينضافوا اليها فعلا ان النيجر هي المنطقه
الامنه الاخيره للقوات الامنيه
الفرنسيه والامريكيه وحتى الالمانيه في
منطقه الساحل وبالتالي في حال استمرار
النجاح الانقلاب والتوتر الحاصل مع الدول
العربيه يعني فقدانه الغرض لهذه المنطقه
ولهذه الدوله المهمه والحساسه لصالح
التمدد الروسي الحاصل منذ فتره في المنطقه
هذا ما سنسال عنه
السيد السفير ديفيد جين ولكن قبل ذلك نرحب
من نيامي بالدكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي من نواكشط الذي ينضم
الينا في هذا النقاش ولكن اود سؤال السفير
ديفيد شين هل الولايات المتحده ودول الغرب
مستعده لخساره هذه المنطقه
لروسيا وبالتالي ان لم تكن مستعده
فهل ستزهم بالدفعه والمشاركه في حل عسكري
قريبا بعد انتهاء هذه المهله التي حددتها
اكواس
الولايات المتحده لم
تقل انه يجب ان يكون هناك تدخل عسكري لحل
المشكله في النيجر لم يكن هناك اي اشاره
الى تدخل عسكري امريكي ولا حتى فرنسي في
هذا القضيه بقدر التعلق الامر دروسيا
حكومه
روسيا هي مستمره بالقول بانها
تودع عوده الوضع الدستوري الى ما كان قائم
عليه قبل الانقلاب وهذا لا يختلف عن
الموقف الغربي عدا عن موقف مجموعه التي
عرضت خدماتها على الانقلابين في النيجر
لكن ربما حسب علمي لم يقبل هذا العرض اذا
الموقف الروسي مشوش حاليا لكن لا اعتقد ان
بالنسبه المتحده هذا مصدر قلق اساسي حاليا
وبالتالي هل تعتقد انها سوف تساعد دول
الاكواس عسكريا اذا قرروا بها التدخل
عسكريا وهي لديها اكبر قاعده للطائرات
المسيره خارج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
موجوده في النيجر
اعتقد انه في التحليل النهائي سيكون هناك
امتعاض كبير
للمضي قدما في اي تدخل عسكري لانه من
الصعوبه
بمكان تنفيذه على الارض لان هناك دول
متعدده في
الجوار رفضت المشاركه نيجيريا لديها حدود
طويله ومن المتوقع ان ياتي يتدخل عسكري من
اراضيها لكن طبعا هناك مشاكل حدوديه تشكل
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر
اذا حتى لو ان بلدان غربيه اخرى اظهرت
رغبه في حل عسكري لكن اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده ستصدر حلا دبلوماسيا دكتور علي
يعقوب برايك يعني ما هو اسنانريو الارجح
في هذا التوقيت والى اي مدى يبدو مرجحا ان
يكون هناك تدخل عسكري والى اي مدى هناك
استعداد لهذا الاحتمال في النيابه
على كل حال بالنسبه لنيابه في النيجر
الذي نتوقعه ان قضيه تدخل العسكري غير
وارده حاليا كثير من الناس
يستبعدونه فيرون انها قد تاتي هناك حلول
اخرى غير التدخل العسكري لان التدخل
العسكري هذا سلبياته اكثر من ايجابياته
وقد
يسبب للذي يقاتل لاجله ليرجع الى السلطه
ان لا يرجع الى السلطه من جديد وحتى لو
رجع قال لا تكون له شعبيه مره ثانيه لان
القضيه الان يا اخوه او في النجا اصبحت
وطنيه ليس قضيه انقلابيه او الانقلابيون
لا الان ناسيرون ان هناك من يريدون ان
يحازموا الدوله النيجر لاجل انقلاب حدث
المثله في بوركينا وفي مالي وفي جينا
لماذا النيجر بالضبط
صراحه الان قضيه التدخل العسكري لا يكون
سهل وان كان حتى لو رجعوا هذا الرئيس
الامور لا تمشي قد ندخل في متاهات اخرى
الاحسن لو استمر هؤلاء ويجبروا على ان
ينزلوا انتخابات في وقت
مبكر جدا لعله قد يكون هذا هو الحل وفي
الجامع على كل حال الشوارع الان ممتلئه
بالمظاهرات وكذا وكذا وكلهم يؤيدون
الانقلابيون يعني هذه القضيه زادت لهم
شعبيه لان الناس الان تحولوا من الانقلاب
الى الدفاع للوطن
حسنا اذا
السيد الهيبه الشيخ ساداتي هل هل قد يكون
هذا براي كاس السيناريو الارجح الحديث عن
ربما فتره انتقاليه وبعدها لا يعود الرئيس
محمد بازون ولكن تنظم انتخابات
الديمقراطيه
هل هذا يمكن ان يكون مقبولا للكل في
النيجر واقليميا ودوليا
فعلا هناك عطب اصاب العقل
الاستراتيجي الغربي في هذه المنطقه هو
الذي افقده مالي هو الذي افقده بوركينا
فاسو لم يكن مالي قاده العسكريون في مالي
ولا في بوركينا فاسو ولا حتى في النيجر
الحام الان حالمون او متحركون او
انقلابيون ضد فرنسا ولم تحركهم العداوه
لفرنسا اطلاقا لكن فرنسا والغرب دفعهم
لذلك بفعل تفوق عطب في الذهن في العقليه
اصابه بان
اسمح لي سؤالي سؤالي كان سؤالي كان اذا
كنت تعتقد انه من المقبول ان تكون هناك
فتره انتقاليه تنظم فيها الامور وللعوده
الى مسار الديمقراطي دون عوده الرئيس
بازون
هذه هذه هي مالات نجاح الانقلاب مالات
نجاح الانقلاب ان يكون هناك فتره انتقاليه
متفق عليها ان يتجاوز الحديث عن عوده
بازون حين يتم التجاوز عن عوده بازون وحين
تتجاوز الاكواس هذا الطرح كما حصل في مالي
وهو كما حصل في بوركينا فاسو يكون هناك
حديث بعد نجاح الانقلاب عن المراحل
الانتقاليه وطريقه اداارتها والطريقه
ومدتها والبرامج السياسيه لها وحقوقها حتى
الافراج عن الرئيس السابق المعتقل هذه
مراحل وترتيبات ما بعد الانقلاب لم تصل
حتى الان الى هذه الطاوله والى هذا
المستوى لم تنزل من برجها الذي الموقف
الصلب المبدئي ضد ضد الانقلاب كما قال من
الصعب جدا التنبؤ
بمالات ايجابيه للتدخل العسكري لكن مع ذلك
الغرب قد يكون يختار النيجر مشتته فيها
حرب اهليه ضائعه
تنضم للسودان ولغيرها من الدول الفاسده في
المنطقه من ان تكون دوله ثالثه تنضم لمحور
مثل مالي وبوركينا فاسو ناهض للغرب في
المنطقه
ايضا
فقط اريد ان انتقل الى السيد اذا سمحت
عندما تقول ان الولايات المتحده تفضل الحل
الدبلوماسي
يعني هل يتضمن الحل الدبلوماسي عدم عوده
الرئيس بازوم وان تنظم
انتخابات ديمقراطيه خلال فتره انتقاليه
معينه
لا يعتبر هذا نجاحا للانقلاب كما يقول
السيداتي
نعم هذا يعني ان الانقلاب سيحققون
هدفهم الوضع رمادي وعلى ان ناخذ بان
الاعتبار كل الاعتبارات المتحده اوضحت
انها تريد عوده الرئيس بازون الى السلطه
لكن في التحليل النهائي الامر يعود الى
شعب النيجر ليقرروا ماذا يحصل في بلادهم
ايضا ليس من الواضح تماما الى اي مدى
الشعبيه التي يحظى بها الانقلابيون في
صفوفها القوات المسلحه نحن لا نعلم هل ان
كل القوات المسلحه تؤيد الانقلابيين ام لا
هذا امر لا نعرفه وقد يؤدي الى مشاكل في
المستقبل اذا هناك قضيه اخرى مثل هذه
ينبغي ان تحل في حل تدخل اكواس عسكريا
وتدخل ايضا مالي وبوركينا فاسو لانهما
هددته بذلك انهما سيتدخلان اذا تدخل
الاكواس العسكريا في هذه الحاله ما هو رد
الفعل الذي تتوقعه من روسيا الموجوده في
المنطقه وكيف يمكن ان تتعامل معه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
كما اوحيت في كلامه من قبل
الوضع او الموقف الروسي مشوش هم لديهم من
جهه الحكومه تقول انها تريد العوده الى
الوضع الدستوري بما يوحي بالعوده الى
الحكم المدني وحكم الرئيس
بازار في نفس الوقت مجموعه تقدم وتعرض
خدماتها العسكريه للقلابين يبدو لان روسيا
ليست في موقع قوي للتدخل
مشغولون باوكرانيا ويبدو انهم لديه موقف
منقسم ازاء ما يحدث في دول الساحه لهذا
السبب لا اعتقد ان هذا مصدر قلق بالغ
للولايات المتحده حاليا الدكتور علي يعقوب
ما هي خيارات قاده الانقلاب في الوقت
الحالي وهم
يواجهون
بانه يعني سيكون هناك تدخل عسكري في حال
انتهاء المهله ويعلنون في ظل ذات الوقت
انهم لن يتراجعوا وايضا حتى لو لم يكن
هناك تدخل عسكري قد تكون هناك عقوبات
اقتصاديه قاسيه فما هي خياراتهم واقعيا في
رايك
بالنسبه للانقلابين ما عندهم اي خيار ايضا
وصلوا الى لا عوده
فيستمرون الامه عليه اما بتدخل العسكري او
بالعقوبات العقوبات اصلا بدات
العقوبات خلاص الان
كهرباء في جامعه تتقطع
في البنوك في صفوف الطويله هذه عقوبات
بدات ولكنها مع الايام سيتعول عليها الناس
والحل العسكري او تداخل العسكري ما اظن
سيكون حلا سليما لبلاد النيجر ولغرب
افريقيا عموما فلذلك كما ترون مجلس الشيوخ
في نيجيريا رفضوا الحل العسكري حل العسكري
ما جاء بمثلها في كل الدول التي استعملت
فيها الحل العسكري ولكن اظن لو في طريقه
الدبلوماسيه قد يصل الى حل
يرجى لبلاد الى ما كان عليه هو بلاد فيه
بوكو حرام وفيه داعش وفيه بعد ماذا ثم
برلم من ان تساعديهم ليحاربوا هؤلاء الناس
وتستقر البلاد تعطون تحاربونه في العاصمه
ايضا لتخربوا عاصمه حش اصلا
لاجل ان يرجع الرئيس الديمقراطي اصلا
صراحه يا اخوه المشكله في افريقيا
الانقلابات لن تنتهي سواء تدخلوا في النيه
او لم يتدخلوا في النيه لان الانتخابات
ليست نجيها
نزيهه الجره لابد ان يداوى اولا وهو
انتخابات المزوره حسنا كل هذه المشاكل
دكتور نعم لكن الضروره احيانا وايضا لا
ينظرون حسنا اود اسال السيد الهبه ولد
الشيخ سيداتي كيف نفهم موقف مجلس الشيوخ
في نيجيريا هل هو رفض بات
ام انه يعني لم يكن هناك طلب مباشر ورد
مباشر هل الى اي مدى يمكن ان يعرقل خطوه
التدخل العسكري المحتمل
من الناحيه القانونيه اظن ان الامر من
صلاحيات الرئيس في نيجيريا وليس من
صلاحيات هيئات مجلس الشيوخ لكن من الناحيه
السياسيه ولناحيه الاجتماعيه ومن ناحيه
المزاج الشعبي العام في المنطقه هناك رفض
شعبي عام في المنطقه لهذه الاساليب لتدخل
العسكري للتعامل بسياسه الكيل بمكيالين مع
الانقلابات
هل هذا اول انقلاب يحصل في النيجر لماذا
كانت القوى الغربيه القوى الغربيه تدعم
الانقلابات وفجاه اصبحت لديها صحوه ضمير
ويعقه الضمير من اجل اعاده الرئيس المنتخب
هذه اشكالات الغرب يعرفها يعرفها ونحن
نعرف علم اليقين ان الغرب لا يريد ليس
السبب لتدخله العسكري
ديمقراطيه ولا ديمقراطيه حقيقيه فهو من
دعمه من اوصل ومن
اوصلت البلاد لهذه المستويات
السفير ديفيد الشن
ليس هناك قلق على مصير
الجماعات المسلحه التي تنشط في هذا المثلث
في مالي والنيجر وبوركينا فاسو ما الذي
يمكن ان يكون مصير هذه الجماعات النشطه في
هذه المنطقه
نعم اثرتم نقطه مهمه للغايه هذه المجموعات
المسلحه بعضها مرتبط بالقاعده بعضها
بتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
حرام هي واحده من المجموعات الاساسيه
بالطبع هذه المجموعه ستحاول استغلال
الموقف لصالحها او ربما قد تحقق مكاسب على
المدى القصير نتيجه
لحاله التشوش التي حصلت الان في النيجر هم
من الان لديهم مكاسب حققوها لا يستهان بها
في بوركينا ومالي هذا يجب ان يكون مصدر
قلق كبير الولايات المتحده والبلدان
الغربيه الدكتور علي يعقوب نفس السؤال لك
كيف يمكن يعني او كيف يؤثر ما يحدث على
الجماعات المسلحه الموجوده في هذه المنطقه
صراحه جماعه المسلحه بدات اصلا تستفيد من
هذه
مشاكل خلال عشره ايام او 11 يوم ولا تنسوا
ان النيجر تختلف عن بوركينا مالي بوركينا
مالي عندهم الدوله الاسلاميه والنصره
والداعش عندنا بوكو حرام في الشرق
البرياني نحن بين
مطلقتين يعني في الشرق الى ابوك وهران مع
نيجيريا وفي المثلث ايضا اننا هؤلاء
الجاهدين الان هذه الايام بالذات لا
اخفيكم بداوا يحاجبون الكره التي على
الحدود ويقتلون الناس ويسوقون الاغنام لان
الجيش منشغل بالدرب التي ستوجه اليهم
المفروض بدلا من هذا الشيء رؤساء الاركان
يشمون لمساعده
هؤلاء الناس لانهم مشكله على كل الدول
الثلاثه وحتى على الغرب اظن امريكا تراجعت
ان التدخل نعم لدينا نحو دقيقه السيد هبه
ولد الشيخ سيداتي ما مصير الاخوه ودوله
مثل غينيا كوناكري تقول انه اي تدخل عسكري
قد يكونوا بدايه لتفكك هذه المنظمه وسؤال
اخر هل ننتظر ايضا انتهاء مهله الاتحاد
الافريقي التي تنتهي بعد ايام
فعلا هناك تحالف او تخادم بين الغزاه
والغلاه والطغاه في هذه المنطقه اوردها ما
هي فيه الان من ويلات ومن ازمات
الاكواس اذا تدخلت عسكريا ستكون لديها
مصاعب بالتماسك اذا لم تتدخل عسكريا
فستبقى مجموعه
لماء انشات من اجله اصلا مجموعه اقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا تهتم بالتبادل وبحركه
البضائع
بالعمله الموحده ولا تدخل في الجوانب
السياسيه والداخليه دي البلدان ما اهميه
المهله التي اعطاها الاتحاد الافريقي حتى
الان هل سينتظر الاكواس نهايتها ليحددوا
اذا ما كانوا سيتداخلون عسكريا ام لا
نحن في لحظات الاخيره من هذه المهله
وبالتالي المهله في عداد المنتهيه
وبالتالي اتوقع انه اذا كانت هناك ضربه لم
تتهيا الظروف لان تكون السريعه وحتى اذا
وجدت هذه الضربه من غير المامون وللامن
بقاء الرئيس بازون حيا
بالتالي ستكون فعلا هذه الضربه اتوقع انها
اذا كانت ستكون ستكون عمليه جراحيه تدخل
عسكري او الدفع بطرف من الجيش لان يكون
فعلا منقلب على المجموعه الجديده للحاكمه
الان في شكرا جزيلا
الشيخ سيداتي الخبير مشان الافريقي من
نيامي الدكتور علي يعقوب الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن السفير ديفيد
شين وساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
للشؤون افريقيا
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]